♪ ♪ ♪
- Au cimetière de Granby
règne une mystérieuse ambiance,
un peu comme si on avait
le sentiment d'être sans cesse
observé.
Au détour des tombes,
une immense roche
attire mon attention.
En créant les Brownies,
Palmer Cox a légué un héritage
inestimable aux enfants.
Mais qui était
ce Palmer Cox et de quel
héritage s'agissait-il?
- Palmer Cox a été un écrivain
illustrateur et poète qui était
connu surtout pour être
l'auteur des Brownies,
des personnages qui ont eu
un immense succès autour
des années 1880 à 1920.
Les Brownies, c'est des
créatures magiques imaginaires
qui sont issues du folklore
écossais. Ce qui différencie
les Brownies des autres
créatures magiques, c'est leur
serviabilité envers les hommes.
Ils ont des pouvoirs magiques
et ils craignent la lumière
du jour, donc ils sortent juste
la nuit pour accomplir leurs
tâches et ils ne se montrent
jamais aux humains.
Les Brownies sont vraiment
caractérisés par une curiosité
qui est presque une curiosité
enfantine et grâce à leur
curiosité donc les Brownies
vont explorer le monde
qui est en changement à cause
de nombreuses découvertes
techniques, scientifiques.
Là, ici, ils sont aux prises
avec le téléphone.
- Avec ses livres illustrés
et ses personnages aussi
fantasques que sympathiques,
Palmer Cox était loin de
se douter qu'il allait créer
un tel engouement auprès
des jeunes qu'on parlera de
"Brownies Mania."
- Il a publié une quinzaine
d'albums des Brownies et en
1924, on a calculé qu'il y a eu
1 million de copies vendues.
Lors du passage
du "Brownie Man" comme on l'a
appelé dans une ville
au Connecticut, il y aurait eu
20 000 enfants qui se seraient
réunis pour venir l'accueillir
pour souligner son passage.
- Palmer Cox dessinait
ses Brownies dans son bureau
situé à Broadway.
La popularité des Brownies
va être telle que
les entreprises de toutes sortes
vont vouloir associer leur nom
à ces curieux personnages.
- Il y a eu une variété
impressionnant d'objets.
Il y a eu de la vaisselle,
il y a eu des tapis, des objets
pour les enfants. Il y a même
du papier peint.
♪ ♪ ♪
Et l'appareil photo,
la fameuse Brownie caméra,
qui est peut-être l'objet
le plus connu qui porte le nom
des Brownies pour lequel on sait
avec certitude que Palmer Cox
n'avait pas donné
son consentement.
Il y a eu des pièces de théâtres
qui ont été tirés de ces
personnages-là, ce qui a aussi
contribué à les faire connaître
pas seulement aux États-Unis,
au Canada et même en Angleterre.
- Certains n'ont pas hésité à
comparer le génial illustrateur
à Lewis Carroll,
l'auteur "d'Alice au pays des
merveilles" qui a autant
traversé les frontières
que les esprits. Mais d'autres
pensent avant tout au père
de Mickey.
- On pourrait peut-être
le comparer à Walt Disney
pour l'idée originale de trouver
des personnages qui n'avaient
pas été exploités avant,
avec son travail artistique
qui a su les transformer
pour qu'ils plaisent vraiment
aux enfants.
- Après son passage triomphal
aux États-Unis, il va revenir
à Granby où il fera bâtir
en 1906 le château Brownies.
- Il y avait des enfants
qui allaient le visiter
régulièrement pour voir
ses dessins, les emmener
en haut de sa tour où il y avait
apparemment un drapeau
avec un Brownies.
- Qu'est devenu le père
des Brownies? Il est mort
à Granby à 84 ans en 1924.
♪ ♪ ♪
Sa maison, le château Brownies,
existe toujours,
mais ses personnages, eux?
- Est-ce qu'ils existent
en chair et en os?
J'en ai pas encore eu la preuve,
mais sûrement que dans
l'imaginaire des gens,
ils existent.
- Et si on va se promener
dans le château des Brownies,
pensez-vous qu'on va être
observé, épié?
- Ça se pourrait.
♪ ♪ ♪